in Berlin werden für die Lehrkräfte
während der Pandemie
37.000 neue Tablet-Computer angeschafft
die Digitalisierung soll endlich auch in
den Schulklassen ankommen doch 12.000
dieser Geräte sind nicht ein einziges
mal angeschaltet worden sie liegen
ungenutzt den Bücherregalen und
Schubladen herum Schaden knapp 12
Millionen Euro
unfassbar was wir für Geld rausschmeißen
und die Kinder kriegen mal wieder nichts
Schüler kriegen eine Sechs wenn sie am
Thema vorbei sind und das ist halt die
Frage was kriegt diese nachtsverwaltung
wenn sie am Thema vorbei ist und falsche
Sachen bestellt hat ich finde das Holz
Kölner Lösung man sollte halt sehen dass
man die Kohle wenn dann richtig also gut
ausgibt
2021 soll es bundesweit Computer fürs
Lehrpersonal geben dafür stellt der Bund
Geld zur Verfügung in Berlin kauft und
verteilt man diese Mini Computer kosten
ca 1000 € pro Stück statt handelsübliche
Laptops gibt's diese kleinen Tablets
das Problem ist aber dass viele
Kolleginnen und Kollegen sagen die sind
überhaupt nicht praxistauglich auf einem
10 zollgerät kann man nicht länger als
zwei Stunden arbeiten es sei denn man
nimmt Haltungsschäden in Kauf in jeder
Behörde in jedem Büro gibt es Vorgaben
für Bildschirmarbeitsplätze weil die
Dinger kleiner sind als ein DIN A4 Blatt
arbeiten viele Lehrer mit ihrem privaten
Computer weiter 12.000 Tablets werden
nicht ein einziges Mal angemeldet
verschwinden ungenutzt im Regal
der Berliner Rechnungshof Brand mag die
Einkaufspolitik der Schulbehörde diese
nazverwaltung hat an den Bedarf der
Lehrer vorbei die Geräte beschafft sie
hat mich vorher kein Konzept entwickelt
wofür brauchen die Lehrer die Geräte hat
auch keine Abfrage bei den Lehrern
gemacht sondern hat einfach die Geräte
beschafft als das Geld da war diese
Ortsverwaltung verteidigt die
Anschaffung der Tablets und kann die
heftige Kritik nicht nachvollziehen die
mobilen dienstgeräte sind sehr gut
ausgestattet und perspektivisch wird die
Benutzung der mobilen dienstgeräte auch
verpflichten festgeschrieben werden
die Menschen in Berlin verstehen nicht
wie man so an der Praxis vorbei
einkaufen kann wenn es um die Lehrer
geht dann hätte ich das erstmal auf die
Lehrer gefragt für was wollen sie die
Tablets überhaupt verwenden was kann man
mit diesen Tablets machen und dann hätte
ich entsprechende Tablette eingekauft
man hätte da wirklich jemand Fragen
sollen der vom Fach ist der davon
vielleicht Ahnung hat oder mit
einbeziehen sollen die missglückte
Millionen Investition ist eine vertane
Chance in Berlin muss man jetzt hoffen
dass aus den vielen ungenutzten
Computern am Ende nicht Elektroschrott
wird